i think it's a little deeper than a
horror movie
but there's is actually a message
somewhere oh and that would be
you know if you're
going around murdering people you you're
pretty messed up real deep david real
deep right there that is our guest
co-host david arquette on the set of the
original screen movie back in 1996 we
have so much footage of you messing
around on that set at the time when you
did that first film did you think okay
this is just a one-off slasher film
no uh wes craven and it's such a great
script and i knew wes craven's work and
he's just such a genius
so and the cast got along so well so i
knew it was gonna be something special
well now here we are five movies later
my goodness the trailer has dropped for
scream coming to theaters in january and
we see you taking on ghost space up
close and personal dewey has survived 25
years what do you think about the new
kids that are coming into this movie i
mean we've got melissa barrera jenna
ortega jack quaid oh they're incredible
they're just such talented actors just i
don't know i i've known jack since he
was a kid i worked with jenna on saving
flora melissa is just an incredible
actress
it was really great to see them all
together i mean i felt like watching the
the cast originally they really
connected i like that i like hearing
that so much but there was one person
missing that i would have liked to sing
there who's that your daughter coco
she's done some acting would you ever
think okay say there's a sixth film
could there be a possibility that
courtney and you the it matches and then
here comes coco in a scream movie oh my
gosh that would be incredible that would
be i mean she loves acting she loves
singing i'm so proud of her she's just
such a beautiful person
from the
i moment you were mine
but how meta would that be i know
completely we pitched in screen four
that we had a kid because we really had
a kid there you go i love it so much you
know there is some other scary news
that's out there right now you uh
recently um acquired the rights to bozo
the clown you own bozo the clown yeah
david i think clowns are terrible i know
that's the problem people have been
inundated with these scary clowns so we
want to bring the good clown back i've
loved bozo since i was a kid okay and it
took me 15 years to acquire the rights
and i just want to you know
just spread
love light and laughter you know through
this clown and all the good clowns that
are out there and we're gonna uh have
him at a interactive circus oh nice
empire circus nice people will be it's
the first time bozo's gonna actually be
in a circus like it was always just in
the studio so i don't know i'm really
excited to to
reintroduce him to the world and this
new group that's coming along with me
it's going to be really fun
[Music]